president Trump's plan to speak at the
opening of a new Civil Rights Museum is
triggering a backlash civil rights icon
Congressman John Lewis along with fellow
Democrat Bennie Thompson said they will
not attend the ceremony tomorrow in
Mississippi they are protesting the
president's policies major Garrett is at
the White House with the latest on this
story major good morning good morning
Mississippi is central to the civil
rights story in America and one of the
young organizers of the 1964 Freedom
Summer
Georgia Congressman John Lewis will
protest again this weekend as
Mississippi celebrates a movement it
used to scorn civil rights is about
equality congressman Bennie Thompson had
harsh words for the president before his
trip to Mississippi we wish the people
the best in the opening ceremony but
this is not the time for to be a
photo-op
but President Trump who has no civil
rights record White House press
secretary Sarah Sanders called a boycott
and affront to the incredible sacrifice
civil rights leaders made to write the
in justices in our history Georgia
Democrat John Lewis sacrificed his will
being for voting rights and was savagely
beaten by state police attempting to
halt the march from Selma to Montgomery
I know it is president-elect as a
legitimate president Lewis also skipped
president Trump's inauguration mr. Trump
wounded by the slight said on Twitter
Lewis should spend more time fixing his
horrible and crime-infested district to
the african-american community I say
vote for Donald J Trump I will fix it
president Trump's campaign won the
support of white nationalists who still
cheer his election not all of those
people were white supremacists
many in the civil rights movement see
the president's harsh criticism of NFL
players kneeling during the national
anthem as racially motivated get that
son of a [ __ ] off the field right now
the n-double-a-cp called the president's
visit to Mississippi an insult former
Democratic governor Ray Mabus said the
president's support of white
supremacists and racism is the exact
opposite of what the museum is about
some african-american officials have
said the president should make the visit
to this museum opening to learn more
about America's bitter racial divide in
the Republican governor of Mississippi
phil Bryant who invited the president
said his trip will bring worldwide
attention to Mississippi and this new
museum viana major thank you